The Tennessee
State House
they have just voted to expel.
State Representative Justin Jones
this is because of a disorderly protest
that he and two other
Democratic colleagues held
last week in the wake of the shootings
in Memphis, Tennessee.
Six people died.
There were a lot of people
who are very angry about
those six murders.
They could have converged,
converged on the Capitol.
Three of those state
representatives, three Democrats
Justin Jones, Justin Pearson
and Gloria Johnson
were disruptive
on the floor of the state House.
One of the three has now been expelled
from the state House.
And the other votes on the other
two will happen imminently.
Let's go to Ryan Young.
Ryan, they did it I have to say, I've it
seems like a rather harsh punishment for
for being unruly on
the floor of the state House.
But when you have a supermajority
you know,
your party can do whatever it wants.
Absolutely.
Jake,
I'm not surprised by this based upon
what Democrats
have been telling us all day long,
they believe this vote would happen.
In fact, we've learned
there are plans for all three members
to walk outside
and do a news conference
after they're expelled.
We do believe
Justin Jones will also be escorted
from inside the chambers
after this procedure happens.
There's hope that he's allowed
to go to his office
to clear it out himself.
But there's also a belief
that he may be walked
directly out
and not even get a chance
to pack up his own items.
This is shocking to so many people
because obviously the focus now,
especially a lot of the media focus
is on this going on
and not the six lives that were lost
just last week.
And even the heroic
officers who went in
to neutralize the threat.
So now you could hear those protesters
screaming in the background.
We thought this would happen.
We're also told
more people
might be swelling into the area
because they want to participate
in the rally
that's going to be held here.
After all, these proceedings are done.
But, Jake,
this is quite a shock
when you think about the fact
that no one has ever been expelled
for a procedural matter.
This comes down to decorum
and the decorum wasn't followed.
Giving the Republicans
a chance to pull this off.
And like you've noted earlier,
these members will have a chance
to run for their seat again.
So we might be back in the same situation
with these same members
back here in a few months
after they probably
will get expelled today.
So there was a motion to adjourn,
but that has been defeated.
And they are now
the Tennessee State House
after expelling Representative
Justin Jones, who you saw there
in the ABC there in the white suit.
He was holding up a fist a second ago.
They are now proceeding to House
Resolution 64
to expel State Representative
Gloria Johnson.
There
you see
a state
representative, former
I should say, ex
state representative Jones
speaking to reporters there.
And Ryan Young, it is shocking,
as you know,
the idea that what has motivated
a state legislative body in Tennessee
a week
after this horrible attack
on a Christian school
where a disturbed person
entered with guns, killed 39 year olds
and killed
three faculty and staff members before
police officers.
Law enforcement from the Memphis area
bravely charged in
and and killed the killed the shooter.
So that what is actually prompted action
is the fact that three state House
Democrats were unruly
on the floor of the state House.
And, look, obviously,
they violated the rules.
Obviously,
they were disruptive and unruly.
And I'm not saying
that they shouldn't be punished,
but it is just
stark you see,
I believe that that that is Gloria
Johnson there on the left.
State Representative Gloria Johnson,
a Democrat.
The action that they are taking right now
is to disenfranchize
hundreds of thousands of Tennesseans
who will now
not have state representation
in the state House.
That's a former state
representative Jones embracing with soon
to be former state representative
Gloria Johnson
on the floor of the Tennessee
Statehouse in Nashville.
What is motivating the legislators
is this act of civil disobedience,
this act of
violating legislative decorum,
and not the murders of these three
individuals, three students,
nine year olds,
that are at a Christian school in Memphis
or the three faculty
members, six individuals murdered.
That is not prompting
the state legislature to act.
It is these requirements.
These state representatives,
these three Democrats, are being rude.
I mean, that is not
unusual.
I would think that well,
and I'm not talking about gun control,
but I would think
there would be some action
taken to try to figure out
how to protect the students
and faculty members.
Yeah, let's
first things first, Jake,
when you think about it, Jones's
sharp tongue.
So there's a lot of people
that he's tussled with
within the state House
who I think are sort of happy,
the fact that they get a chance
to take away his seat.
We saw today
how he was able to defend himself
so very
well as he was talking back and forth
with lawmakers.
But a lot of people believe
before we even got here today
that this was a done deal,
that he was going to be gone
at the least.
And something people
have been trying to change things.
But here's the thing.
We've been talking
to teachers all day long
who spent their entire
time to come down here
imploring lawmakers
hopefully to change their mind
on this one.
And maybe focus more on gun legislation.
I talked to a Republican woman off
camera who said
she didn't want to go on camera,
but she said the whole idea here, look,
we live in the south.
I don't
expect them to take away our guns.
But she wanted to see something change
to make school kids safe.
And so we heard that over
and over from people
saying maybe the Republican
Democratic talking points
needed to go away
just a little bit
in order to make some sort of space here
to help children out.
We had teachers
crying on air
with us today
begging for change
because they don't know
what to tell their students
because they say their own students
expect for something to happen in school.
Now, it's that sad fear
that we should be dealing with.
Front and center,
according to the protesters
who came here.
And then you have this action
taking place,
a change in state history, really,
when you think about
how this is going to move forward.
And, of course,
with that Republican supermajority,
they make the rules.
And so these three lawmakers
pretty much challenged that rule
governing body
and decorum is going to win out
in this one.
In terms of them
being able to make this change.
Now, you hear people
on the floor right now
saying this is a change for America
and democracy, and that's something
we're going to think about
moving forward.
Holly, what is your reaction
to what we're seeing here on the side?
On one side of the screen?
On the left,
you see State Representative Justin Jones
in his white suit holding up his fist.
He was there for a second outside
the chamber.
He has been ejected.
He has been expelled.
Called from the state legislature
for the unruly behavior from last week.
And we see on the right side
of the screen, state Representative
Roy Johnson, who is about to be expelled.
I Holly, are you surprised that
this is what the state legislature
is choosing to act on, even though
six innocent people were murdered
in a Tennessee school
and a Christian school?
And and that would seem to me,
just as a citizen,
to be more offensive than the
than the rude behavior
we saw a time to every week.
I know
I'm a native Tennessean
and I'm sadly not.
This is no surprise to me.
It's very it's very upsetting to
me as a Tennessean.
What this is about is the
fact that the Republican super majority
has never liked Gary Johnson.
They don't like Justin Jones
and they don't like Justin Pierson.
And this has given them an opportunity
to take some actions
to take revenge on them for speaking up.
Let's listen. He's got to listen.
Max is done.
Yeah.
Let's just let's let's let's listen in
to State Representative
Jones, a former state
representative Jones.
Let's listen to him.
The support,
the others who are still in their
and this does not seem like America
can spell voices of opposition to this.
That is a signal of authoritarianism.
And it is very dangerous.
And I hope that as a nation watches that,
at least that we face,
we could miss this light onto this
to say that
this should sound the alarm
across the nation.
It's a very dangerous territory.
Eugene Robinson there,
who who are still in
the first question, say,
what would you say to them?
There are only three members of the 74.
I mean, we're in this together
that we the three of us,
we stand together as I'm talking about
the need to go support them.
You know, I can't be on the House floor
right now.
I'm going to go to the galleries
and stay for the hearing
because we are in this together.
And it's not one that we represent
you know, we're multi-racial
as a generational.
We represent Memphis,
Nashville, Knoxville.
We stand united.
And the people across
the nation are paying attention
to what's happening
because this is not in the air.
But what they did was signal that that
if we don't act,
we knew we would lose out on
Saturday was a signal that we have left
a lot of things in Tennessee
and that we are
on the path toward authoritarianism.
But on where you were to, again,
I have no idea.
You know,
what are my next steps in terms
of responding to this extreme measure?
But I will continue to show up
for the people who continue to talk to,
you know, to demand action on common
sense gun laws,
because what we were saying was, let's
let us pass an assault weapons ban.
Let's take action.
And they responded
by assaulting democracy
So thank you all so much.
Thank you, Representative Jones.
I don't have any next steps,
but I will continue to show up
in this Capitol with these young people
and whether I'm in that chamber outside.
And so we don't know what's next.
I'm going to consult my legal team
because I believe that
what they did was unconstitutional.
I believe that it violated,
you know, many of our rights.
And so at the silence
walk, rather than just me, my district.
78,000 people have lost their
their vote and their voice
because of the extreme actions
of this body.
So I'll continue to show up
and we must continue to
hold them accountable.